本周节目由24年专研生发品牌达飞星冠名播出，
只脱生发就选达飞星。
嗨各位早上好呀，今天是2026年的6月8号，星期一。
这里是生动早咖啡，会是来自生动活泼的梦一。
通过AI微信的交互方式可能会发生怎样的变化。
白老会票房的增长动力为什么正在从音乐剧转向话剧。
今天上半部分的早咖啡就会来回答这些问题。
今天节目的下半端想和你聊聊美国的小费文化。
再过几天2026世界杯就要开幕了，
随着大量的游客湧入美国，
一些美国的餐馆正在考虑，
在世界杯期间直接把20%的小费加入到顾客的最终账单里。
在大多数国家小费更像是一种对服务人员的感谢，
给不给，给多给少，通常和服务体验有关。
但是小费文化在美国有些不太一样，
虽然名义上依然是顾客的自愿行为，
但是皮尤研究中心近期的调查发现，
大部分的美国人认为给小费已经成为了日常消费的惯例。
为了防止海外游客不知道要给小费的情况发生，
部分参观的从业者才会想出，
在世界杯期间强制收小费的办法。
那为什么小费会在今天的美国那么普遍，
甚至有着很强的社会压力？
参观强制收小费可能会带来一些影响。
我们先来浏览几条最近的商业科技动态，
稍后的清解读时间一起和你来了解这个话题。
微信向手机厂商开放智能体接口。
根据财星6月4号的报道，
微信正在和华为、小米、OPPO还有Vivo等手机厂商合作，
推出智能体功能。
目前，荣耀已经率先进行了适配，
用户可以通过荣耀手机的AI助理发起微信语音，
或者是视频通话，
也可以向指定的微信好友发送消息。
36颗的分析认为，
腾讯这次和手机厂商的合作，
是让手机系统的AI智能体，
比如华为、小异、小米、小爱，
能够直接地和微信内部的智能体对话。
而之前的豆包手机，
则是通过读取屏幕上的信息，
模拟点击屏幕来操作微信，
照过了微信的授权。
腾讯总裁刘志平此前明确的表示，
手机操作系统的智能体可以操控应用，
但是必须获得应用的许可。
财新认为微信是
现在国内移动互联网最成熟的封闭生态，
除了社交功能，
还有以视频号和公众号为主的内容分发平台，
并且能够通过广告、电商、支付等环节，
实现商业化。
有行业人士在接受36颗采访的时候表示，
任何手机的智能体如果不能调用微信，
就不能算是一个真正的系统级智能体。
lululemon 中美表现分化。
6月4号运动服饰品牌lululemon。
发布了最近一个嫉妒的财报，
他们的营收增长了4.3%，
但是近利润同比下滑接近四成。
lululemon 的增长主要是由中国市场拉动，
美国和加拿大的收入都在减少，
另外他们还预计，
今年全年的收入可能会出现下滑的情况。
财报发布之后，
他们的股价下跌超过10%，
也创下了近8年以来的新低。
品牌的管理层表示，
他们最近陷入了有害化学物质的争议，
公司创始人和董事会的矛盾，
以及社交媒体的负面评价，
都对销售造成了影响。
美国政府考虑入股 AI 公司。
6月6号,
特朗普表示美国政府正在探讨，
持有 AI 公司的股份。
根据 CNBC 的报导，
这个想法最早由 OpenAI 的 CEO Sam Altman 提出，
OpenAI 今年 4 月,。
还建议设立一个公共财富基金，
由 AI 公司捐赠部分的股权，
让公众分享 AI 增长的收益。
上周， Sam Altman 还在华盛顿。
和美国政府官员以及国会议员。
讨论了相关话题。
另外， 6 月 6 号 SpaceX 披露，
他们和 Google 签署了一份总价值。
超过 300 亿美元的算力租赁协议。
Google 从今年 10 月起，
每个月向 SpaceX 支付 9.2 亿美元，
合同持续到 2029 年。
Google 将会获得 SpaceX 11 万块芯片的使用权。
而 SpaceX 此前也已经和 Anthropic 达成过类似的协议。
信用时报的分析认为，
SpaceX 选择把算力租赁给竞争对手，
反映出马斯克的 Grok 已经落后于同行了。
不过，Google 的发言人表示，
这是一份过度性的协议，
他们 Gemini 的客户需求，
已经大幅度的超过了预期。
白老会票房创下历史新高。
根据 CNBC 6 月 5 号的报道，
从去年 5 月到今年 5 月，
白老会的总票房超过了 19 亿美元，
创下历史新高。
数据显示，整体的票房收入增长了 3.5%。
观众人次和平均票价都在上涨。
不过，推动票房增长的结构也正在变化。
化剧的观众人次，增长了接近 14%。
音乐剧反而出现了下降。
陆白老会制作人表示，
他们越来越倾向于选择有知名度的题材，
还有自带观众基础的明星阵容。
优海来屋明星出演的话剧不仅可以收取更高的票价，
同时还能够避免全新音乐剧可能不太受欢迎的风险。
那以上就是我们编辑部为你书里的几条最近的商业科技动态。
下面和我一起走进今天的清洁读，
来聊聊美国的小费文化。
欢迎来到今天的清洁读。
对于我们大多数的国人来说，
如果消费的时候遇到了很好的服务，
我们通常的做法应该都是。
五星好评，加上点赞推荐。
给小费似乎并不是我们习惯的选择。
但是经常去国外旅游。
或者本身就生活在海外的听众你可能就会发现，
小费在部分国家还是一个相对普遍的现象。
关于小费制度的起源，
历史学家克里塞格雷夫。
在美国社会小费史这本书当中写道，
在十六世纪的英国，
前去朋友家作客的富裕旅行者，
常常会给主人的仆人留下一些钱。
这笔钱更像是一种。
对他们额外照顾来访客人的感谢和补偿。
大约也是在同一时期，
类似的现象也开始在英国的一些咖啡馆出现。
顾客为了获得更好的服务，
也会给服务人员小费一次鼓励。
而给小费的现象也有此，
从英国传播到了欧洲各个国家。
虽然今天世界各地的小费喜俗差异很大，
但是总体来说给小费这件事，
普遍的原则仍然是顾客自愿，
人们可能会因为得到了优质的服务，
基于感谢性质的小费，金额也是可多可少。
但小费文化在今天的美国却有些不太一样，
首先美国人对小费到底是可选项还是必选项，
其实也会有着不同的看法。
华尔街日报一项调研发现，
有大约20%的受访美国人认为给小费是可选项，
有29%的受访者认为这更多的是义务。
而占比接近一半的受访对象则表示，
这取决于具体的情况。
华尔街日报的评论认为，
小费在美国依然缺乏统一的规则或者是预期，
世界其他地区的人也普遍认为，
美国人有点过于注重小费了。
澳大利亚航空公司的一本旅行指南，
甚至曾经建议前往美国的旅客，
在美国，小费只是名义上的可选项。
除此之外，这些年在美国还出现了一种叫做tipflation，
也就是小费膨胀的趋势。
皮尤研究中心的报告显示，
绝大多数的美国人认为，
他们现在被要求给服务人员小费的频率比过去更高，
要给小费的地方也会更多了。
除了传统的餐厅，
现在在理发店、宠物中心、便利店，
甚至加油站的自助服务中端上都出现了小费提示。
康奈尔大学、酒店管理学教授、
小费心理学的作者麦克尔林恩表示，
美国可以说是世界上最乐于给小费的国家了。
这里需要给小费的行业不仅更多，
而且美国人给的小费金额也会更高。
国家地理的文章写道在大多数国家，
小费是一种表达谢谢的方式，
但在美国，小费却像是强制性的，
就像是一种隐形税。
那为什么今天美国的小费名义上自愿，
但现实中却有很强的社会压力呢？
原因之一，南北战争后的遗留问题，
导致小费被欠入了服务业的工资结构里。
在南北战争之前，
美国餐厅的服务人员实际上大多都是白人男性，
他们不收小费，只拿工资。
1950年代,
一些去欧洲旅行的赋予美国人，
把给小费的习惯也带回到了美国。
不过在那个时候，
很多美国人其实是很反感这种做法的，
觉得他带着欧洲阶级社会里主人赏赐仆人的意味，
这也和美国社会所强调平等的观念并不相符合。
然而今天的美国，
小费却在服务业里逐渐的扩散，
加州大学博克力分校，
食品劳工研究中心的主任杰亚拉曼认为，
这主要是源自南北战争之后的劳动力变化。
战争结束之后，
宪法修正案废除了奴隶制，
那那些获得自由的人，
可以选择的工作机会仍然十分有限。
于是餐饮业的雇主就想到了。
可以雇佣兴庆获得自由，
同时薪资低廉的黑人，
尤其是来自于南方的黑人女性。
他们告诉这些珍惜收入机会的女性，
我们不会给你们工资，
你们只能够靠这种源自欧洲的，
一种叫做小费的东西生活。
随着酒店和餐营业的变革，
小费习俗也开始逐渐蔓延到了这些服务行业。
后来在1938年罗斯福星政期间，
美国通过了公平劳动标准法，
开始建立联邦最低工资制度，
几乎所有的行业都获得了联邦最低工资的保障。
餐馆、酒店业也被纳入其中，
不过法律还是给收取小费的员工开了一个例外，
雇主可以把顾客给服务人员的小费，
算作自己支付最低工资的一部分。
这个机制叫做Tip Credit，小费抵扣，
也就是说雇主可以把员工收到的一部分小费算进他们最低工资里。
而这个制度的结果就是，
美国联邦层面到现在，
仍然允许一些收取小费的员工，
现金实薪可以只有2.13美元。
只要员工的基本工资加上小费，
最后能够达到每小时7.25美元的联邦最低工资，
雇主就算是满足了法律的要求。
如果加上了小费，仍然没有达到7.25美元，
雇主才需要补足差额。
而这项机制对于餐厅老板们来说也非常有吸引力，
因为它减轻了他们提高工资的压力，
同时也让小费从顾客额外表达感谢的钱，
变成了服务人员工资结构中的组成部分。
也正因为如此，美国餐馆里的小费名义上仍然是自愿的，
但是顾客也会意识到，
如果自己不给，服务员可能真的会少赚一部分收入。
时代杂志的报道显示，
在美国接近65万家餐厅当中，
绝大多数的服务员或者是调酒师的工资，
都是需要依赖小费补贴的。
原因之二，美国餐厅竞争激烈，
消费者又高度关注彩单标价。
对于大部分的美国独立餐厅来说，
小费制度还有一个现实作用，
那就是它能够让菜单上的价格看起来更低。
康奈尔大学收入的一篇相关论文指出，
因为小费相当于把一部分人工成本，
后制给顾客来承担，
而不是在菜单上体现，
所以这其实也是一种价格分拆的做法。
顾客在看菜单的时候，往往会先看菜价本身，
而不会马上把菜价加小费算成总成本，
所以小费也是一种降低顾客光顾门槛的方法。
其实之前也有一些餐厅想要通过提高菜价来取代小费，
但是这些尝试都不太成功。
根据行业媒体的报道，2015年的时候，
美国一家连锁海鲜餐厅叫做Jose Crab Shack，
曾经对18家门店进行了5小费模式的探索，
但是了一段时间之后，
他们又把试点的门店缩小到了4家，
原因就是，那些参与试点门店的平均客流。
都下降了8%-10%.。
后来这个案例也进入到了学术研究，
消费者行为领域的学术期刊，
消费者事务杂志的一项研究，
也分析了他的线上评分，
发现保留小费制度的门店，
顾客评价，反倒是要高于那些。
取消小费，把服务费算进菜价的门店里。
康奈尔大学的研究论文指出，
如果顾客将一家价格较高，
而且无需支付小费的餐厅，
和一家价格比较低，
但是需要支付小费的餐厅进行比较的时候，
他们就会认为，不需要支付小费的餐厅，
更贵，即便是最终他们支付的费用是相同的。
原因之三，
疫情、通胀和数字支付系统。
共同助长了小费的膨胀。
行业媒体Nation's Restaurant News。
提到，新冠疫情期间，餐饮业停业，
人们的生计受到威胁，
所以顾客也被鼓励要更加慷慨地给服务人员小费。
之前10%-15%是常态，
而现在在某些地方，
30%的小费已经成为了标准。
约翰·霍普金斯大学的一篇分析文章也提到，
零售业本来就竞争激烈，
通货膨胀加就了市场竞争。
一些企业在疫情之后还没有完全恢复，
他们寄灭零着不能提价的压力，
同时又不得不支付更高的公司来雇佣员工，
于是，让顾客支付更多的小费，
变成了一种转价压力的选择。
与此同时，小费心理学的作者麦克尔·林恩指出，
数字支付中端的广泛应用又进一步加剧了小费膨胀的趋势，
这些支付系统界面会要求顾客在付款之前，
选择一个固定的小费金额。
虽然你可以一见拒绝或者更改金额，
但是在服务人员的注释之下，
很多人仍然会感到尴尬。
而且这些支付中端也蔓延到了一些。
几乎没有什么服务的消费场景，
比如你只是去买杯咖啡，
或者是一份外带的午餐。
在这些门店的自助结账机上，
也会提醒你，需要支付小费。
现如今，美国即将迎来世界杯，
为了避免海外游客不熟悉美国的小费文化，
结账的时候没有留下小费，
一些美国餐厅准备直接把20%的小费。
加进顾客的最终账单里。
而这种强制收取小费的方式也会带来新的麻烦，
比如可能会激怒那些生活在举办城市，
本来就捉惊见肘的当地居民，
强制的20%小费可能会被理解为又一笔涨价。
另外，根据美国国税局的规定，
只有自愿支付的小费，
而非强制性服务费的一部分，
才能够享受最高2.5万美元的小费所得税抵扣。
强制收取小费的举措，
可能就意味着，
原本那些可以享受小费免税的服务人员，
将会面临着更高的税收负担。
那你支付过小费吗？
如果是的话，
你还记得当时在哪里又是出于什么样的理由给的小费吗？
欢迎在评论区后我们一块来讨论。
另外，今天节目到最后，
还想和你一起来关注，
许多人可能都会遇到的头发的问题。
人每天都会掉50-100根头发，
这是人体正常的新神代谢。
但长期熬夜，精神紧绷，
会影响体内激素水平，
引发熊激素性头发。
男性通常表现为发气线厚移，
头顶稀疏，
女性则主要表现为发风变宽，
整体发量变薄。
随着现代生活节奏加快，
脱发已经是一个相当普遍的现象。
目前，敏诺蒂尔是市面上。
广泛使用的外用生发成分之一。
其实，他最初是一种治疗高血压的口服药物，
后来医生意外发现，
长期服药的患者出现了多毛的副作用，
于是，敏诺蒂尔才开始被研究用于脱发治疗。
敏诺蒂尔的生发原理是刺激毛囊细胞增值分化，
延长毛发的生长期。
作为上市药企，
达菲星专研生发24年，
其独家低敏生发配方中添加了STS。
刘戴·刘酸大成分，
可以对抗毛囊危严症，
改善头皮环境，
帮助敏诺蒂尔更稳定的发挥治疗效果。
女性或者头皮敏感的人群。
可以选择温和不刺激的2%农度，
男性或者中度以上的脱发人群。
可以选择清爽不油腻的5%农度。
此外，达菲星还推出了防脱洗发水，
添加了7种中药植醉，
拥有国家防脱特征和防脱专利技术，
搭配敏诺蒂尔坚持按量使用效果更好。
我们会在本周节目评论区的互动听友中。
抽取5位送出达菲星的产品。
有需要的听友也可以点击节目。
收诺斯里的优惠链接，
大醋期间下单更优惠。
买达菲星就上淘宝APP。
以上就是今天节目的全部内容，
生动早咖啡，
与你明天一早再会。